okay let's start with the story i was
hoping to get to yesterday didn't have
time it's sort of like rounding out the
anti-vaxx police officer that died of
kovid who was on ivermectin the
anti-vaxx another anti-vaxx right-wing
radio host who died of covid
this is the anti-mask militia dude
who has died of kovid
his name uh was caleb wallace caleb
wallace anti-mask organizer and
co-founder of the san angelo freedom
defenders
has died of covet 19. this is a really
sad story
caleb wallace
um co-founder of san angelo freedom
defenders and west texas minutemen state
coordinator has died from causes related
to covet 19 according to an update on
gofundme by his wife jessica wallace
caleb has peacefully passed on
he will forever live in our hearts and
minds
reads the most recent update
this is from the
stay-at-home mom of three
expecting a fourth child
late next month
while wallace has become a secular had
become a semi-regular feature in local
news through his conservative activism
it was his battle with kovid that
garnered the national spotlight after
his family's struggle was featured in an
article published in the san angelo
standard times on august 22nd
his organization of the freedom rally a
protest against state and local mass
requirements during the summer of 2020
made him a figure of some prominence
among those in the community who were
opposed to mask mandates the new york
times reports san angelo mayor brenda
gunter commented in an interview they
believe the coronavirus was a hoax
and they believed the government was
being too heavy-handed when it came to
masks
yahoo news reports on this as well
texas anti-mask freedom rally organizer
fighting for his life with covet 19 this
was just a friday before he died at that
time his wife jessica wallace wrote that
she had a heartbreaking update quote
he's not doing good it's not looking in
our favor his lungs are stiff due to the
fibrosis
they called and said they've run out of
options for him
and asked if i would consent to a do not
resuscitate and it would be up to us
when to stop treatments my heart just
can't i can't imagine my life without
him at the time the 30 year old wallace
had been unconscious ventilated and
heavily sedated
in july of 2020 he reportedly organized
a freedom rally to be against government
control of our lives
uh they hosted a separate rally under
the san angelo freedom defenders last
year to quote end covered tyranny
he um i mean listen it's what what what
else is there to say you know
um here is video of caleb wallace saying
covet guidelines make no sense
and kovid's just fine to live with just
live with it
the basic
rights of
breathing free air moving about freely
going into businesses without being
harassed
about a mask or about
you know these doctors levying these
ridiculous restrictions upon its
citizens with no representation in
city council commissioner's courts
that's judge steve floyd nowhere to be
found on this
so
we our group people were not just a
bunch of angry people we're people that
yes we are fed up but we also want to
provide options and provide
a positive option and
with this rally this is important to
us as a group because
we have to start
making changes now reverse the trend
back to normalcy back before march 2020
and what we're seeing
now is people were scared
people we were kind of unsure what this
was all about we were being fed
stuff from the top saying hey this is
this is super dangerous
and
you know we were we were all kind of
unsure i mean rightly so
but the science is out there and it's
saying otherwise that
this is perfectly fine to live with it's
deadly to certain people
but we another never in the history of
this country we've locked down healthy
people with the sick and as i mentioned
his wife is due with their fourth child
on september 27th
um
a pregnant wife and three
young kids
now of course you can be vaccinated and
die that can happen
it is very unlikely
that a 30 year old vaccinated individual
would have died if he had gotten the
free vaccine that is now widely
available
at basically any pharmacy
if this story doesn't convince people
i don't think anything will
and just think back to some of those
trump rallies i remember it's like
burned into my mind there was a trump
rally and we were covering it before it
started and there was like a sort of
scan of the crowd and there was a woman
maybe
you know 60ish
with a shirt on and the back of the
shirt had on it my son died of covid
and i'm still here at the rally this was
before vaccines were even available this
was like the summer last summer
um i think that there are millions and
millions of people who are just beyond
reach that's it
there's no way around it and
this is a tragic story at least as far
as these kids are concerned you can say
whatever you want about listen caleb
wallace chose not to get vaccinated
the kids didn't choose to have an idiot
dad who was going to refuse to get
vaccinated a vaccine that's free and
likely would have would have prevented
him from dying not a hundred percent but
likely would have prevented him from
dying the kids didn't choose that and
now they grow up without a father and
this fourth baby about to be born in
late september uh is born
uh and will have no dad
because of this guy's mistaken beliefs
think whatever you want about him and we
can talk about should we feel bad for
for the the individuals who choose not
to get the vaccine or not and are they
victims of misinformation or are they
bad people or are they both or we don't
know
but the kids aren't guilty of anything
and um it is just if this doesn't
convince people
i truly don't know what will
one of our sponsors is for sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 thousand five star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get 100 percent of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off and free shipping
when you go to four sigmatic dot com
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video